uh
chair we're now live on youtube chris
good morning and welcome to timbridge
district council's virtual planning
committee
on tuesday the 16th of february 2021
i'm your chair mike haynes all
participants here today
are taking part remotely and the
committee is being viewed
online and recorded so please bear this
in mind throughout the meeting
in the event of a break in the internet
connection or a power cut
please bear with us as we try to
reconnect
if we're not able to reconnect after 15
minutes the meeting will be adjourned
and reconvened at a later date please
check the committee page on our website
for further details
please make sure all microphones are
muted when you are not speaking
to avoid any background noise levels
please keep your points short
and do not interrupt when someone is
speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic
blue i think it's yellow now and and
wait to be called
all councillors have been sent the
agenda for today's meeting
any members of the public who want to
view the agenda can do so by visiting
our website
teamridge.gov dot uk
i will now start the committee by doing
the roll call of everyone here presents
and when you hear your name please
confirm confirm it by saying
present chris can you do the role call
please
thank you chair counselor janet bradford
councillor bellevant president
councillor clarence
president councillor colclough president
councillor cox president
councillor hayes has given his apologies
um councillor hook councilman haynes is
here
oh sorry counselor
uh counselor hook counselor jeffrey
councillor kurzweil councillor mcgregor
present counselor nuttel president
councillor nutley councillor patch
president councillor parker
he's given his apologies there was an
email earlier this morning
thank you chair um councillor goodman
bradbury
present and councillor haynes president
can i now introduce the officers who are
with us this morning
um eastman is the business manager for
planning
we have planning offices helen addison
and
taya cottrell we also have
suzanne wolford the planning solicitor
chris morgan democratic services officer
okay those are the introductions
i can go on then to the agenda
item one on the agenda apologies for
absence so i've mentioned
councillor parker are there any others
chris um no other apologies for absence
chair
thank you item two is to confirm the
minutes of the last meeting well i
looked through those myself yesterday in
the evening and
can find one correction that needs to be
made
on page five halfway down this is the
one for
mulberry street in tinmuth it says it
was proposed by council j hook and
seconded by councillor parker that
permission be refused
that should read that the item is
deferred
because on the minutes it then follows
that i i proposed an amendment that it
be
that the permission be granted and that
obviously would have been a direct
negative
so having looked back through the
recording of that part part i can
confirm
that the um correction should be it
changes from permission be refused
to the item be deferred
also two pages later there's a typo
where it's got the wrong order of words
in the sentence
particularly stuck out because it
related to me
it's at the top of page eight
paragraph it says it was proposed by
council government bradbury and seconded
haines by a councillor
so it should be by councillor haynes so
it's just a typo there
so i've got those two corrections to to
make is anyone else have any
points on the minutes uh
cousin nutley yeah i keep putting the
hand up he's disappearing for some
reason
on page 25 declarations of interest
i'm not sure whether it reads quite
correctly
it says councilman that be declared an
interest in application 20
so on as they had a relationship with
the applicant and neighbor
that don't sound quite right to me
i think it's it's the sort of use of the
word relationship i don't
so it's item 25 is it you're referring
to yes yes
i'm trying to find the page page three
on my uh
legendary i i i noted i noticed where it
said it
um but i can't remember where because i
thought at the time when i read it it's
it's it's the use of the word
relationship i think in
modern times has has been sort of
generally taken to mean something else
um but i think it's correct isn't it i
mean
did you wish to suggest an alternative
use of words
it did it just looked the wrong wording
for me when i was you know it looked
like i'd had a relationship
if you just wanted to if you do think of
a word to
replace relationship i'd be happy to a
close friend
a close friend or something of that
nature
that probably sounds a bit better i
think yeah okay right thank you
anybody else can't see everyone on the
screen i haven't got any other hands
up um i can see
no so it's something like i'd move the
minutes with that
those type two or three mighty minor
amendments that's been consecrated by
councillor huntley
can ask for a show of hands then please
and sort of there's any contention here
okay right anyone against
those i can see on my screen can you see
everyone on your screen chris
uh yes chad i can see everyone on my
screen no no be against them
okay right so those are carried so
that's item two
item three declaration of minutes
so i'm trying to get rid of this bit at
the top of my commuter i've got
councillor
jackie hook and councillor lynn goodman
bradbury
thank you um yeah i'd like to declare an
interest in the two applications at
dornerfield nipple pen
since i'm a personal friend of counselor
dewhurst
and it's his personal interest in the
application which is the reason for it
coming to committee
um and i won't speak or vote on those
two applications
thank you council governor bradbury
uh um not the same item but same reason
i'm a
personal friend of councillor taylor and
an item2002289
um in dawlish and the reason for that
coming to council is because he's a
councillor as well so i i won't
speak or vote on that one thank you okay
thank you
right so there's anyone else take your
hands down then
please thank you right um
item four chairman's announcement says a
couple of
things i've announced the first one is
excuse me i think captain mcgregor was
trying to
um thank you i can see that now yeah
i've got
a thing at the top of my computer still
which makes it more difficult
to display those and can't see everyone
sorry council mcgregor yeah it was just
uh
to um declare an interest in that i'm a
colleague on the executive with
councillor
taylor and councillor dewhurst although
um
i will speak and and um and vote on
these applicants is just to let
you know that i am i work on the
executive with both of them
yeah i think inevitably with members of
the council having
applications before us then there will
be this
level of of knowing people but um
clearly if
that applied to all of us we couldn't
make a decision um but
yeah we're i think we're all aware of
different people's
knowledge but it's it's where you've got
a closer relationship than
with the sort of rest i think it
particularly becomes significant thank
you very much for that
okay um announcements item four
first one is as i've intimated earlier i
will
try and give us a comfort break about 11
30. obviously i'll get one fitted in at
some point it's just a
question of where we are on the agenda
that becomes convenient to do that
and the other item is one for roz to
give us a brief update on
um i've read the draft but she can just
give us an update on the um situation
with
moving forward with the recommendations
from the planning advisory service
uh recommendations ros
thank you chair so um we had uh
previously let you guys know through the
members newsletter that we were hoping
to
have a discussion today about the in
particular two recommendations from the
paz report relating to
arrangements for site visits and
arrangements for public speaking
um i prepared a note that outlines uh
the recommendation
um and also the advice um
our current position and the advice from
the the local government association in
the way that planning committees should
operate
but conversations with colleagues and
democratic services have suggested that
we
should look at that a little bit in more
detail
and consider whether or not we want to
make some recommendations to you
as part of that rather than that simply
being an information report which is how
it's prepared
at the moment so it's proposed that we
bring that to you in march
uh instead so my apologies that there is
uh this delay
um but i hope you can understand why
thank you
right that's item uh
four item five public participation
uh i can advise members that there are
two speakers on the
first application we've got the one in
tim with two of
two objectives to that major application
um
there is one person speaking on each of
the two
on the dornerfield caravan
site and for the applegath while in
bishop's
and there is an an objector and a
supporter
who have indicated they wish to speak on
those
right on to item six then which is the
planning applications to consider for
consideration
the first one of those is the one at
trinity nursery in timmouth
so i'll hand over here to um
helen please
oh okay thank you very much um chris
am i able to present uh the powerpoint
uh you should be able to now thanks
helen okay
thank you
okay so i can't see what you can see
can you can you just confirm that you
can see there can you enlarge it it's on
smaller yeah
that's it right i can see that
right so that that should be uh that
should be good now
yeah okay um so i just want to start off
by saying i've received one late
representation that's not reported in
the um
of the reports to you and it's from a
miss rebecca hartley at flat one
willowdean
which is five ferndale road and she says
the site is not big enough the access is
dangerous the plans are ugly and out of
keeping the block is overwhelming
and looks directly on to established
homes all around
so this slide shows you the location
of the application site
this is buckeridge road which runs along
here
and there is a small access track
that provides access to convent lodge on
the corner
here also provides access to number 13
ferndale road here which would be used
to
access the site so to the north
this is trinity school here and
to the east south and west are
residential properties some of them in
flats and oak beer house here
and 13 ferndale road are single
dwellings there are no
uh planning designations on the site
apart from
there is a line of mature trees along
the back the northern boundary with
trinity school
which are protected by a tree
preservation order
so can i just stop you for a minute
please
i think i was getting ahead of myself if
i could just ask chris
i forgot we've got two public speakers
on this item
and i didn't invite you or ask you to
bring them from the waiting room in
which case we'll have to probably start
again on the presentation helen chris
can you confirm please
yes i'm sorry chair there was two public
speakers i just didn't want to
interrupt the presentation i'll bring
them in now
i mean i'm sorry i i with everything i i
forgot
that the procedure that i needed to do
so if we could have them in
and when i see that they're there i'll
just i'm afraid i'll have to ask you to
start again helen
you haven't gone too far so we'll do
that please
absolutely no problem yes we've hardly
started
if you can let me know when when like i
can see
one of the people is in um
it's the mrs hartley i think is the the
other one you referred to the letter
that
i can't see yet they're both there chair
there are names for both of them um
showing on my screen uh we've got
michael hartley and john perkins both
yeah that's right i can see them both
now thank you yeah can i
welcome um the two public speakers i i
forgot to invite you into the
main part of the meeting before the
office's presentation
so the officer will now restart the
presentation gen come too far
okay back to you apologies to everyone
thank you
thank you uh i say i want to start off
by saying that we've received one
late representation um following
publication of the officers
report an update report and this is from
miss rebecca
hartley at flat one willowdean five
ferndale road
and in her representation she says the
site is not big enough
the access is dangerous the plans are
ugly and out of keeping and the block is
overwhelming and looks
directly into established homes all
around
so this plan shows the location of the
application site
which is at this rectangular site here
buck ridge road runs to the west of the
site
and the site is accessed from an
existing track
road from uh buckeridge road and this
says
convent lodge which a group of flats
here it also
provides vehicular access to number 13
ferndale road which is
located here to the north of the site
is trinity school in this location here
and to the east south and west of
properties
in residential use some of them are in
flats
such as convent lodge and at 5 and 11
ferndale road
and single dwelling houses at oak beer
house
and 13 ferndale road there are no
designations relating to the site uh in
planning terms
apart from there are a line of mature
trees which are actually in the trinity
school
site along the northern boundary of the
site and those are protected by
a tree preservation order
the site has no buildings on it
the western half has been used in the
past by team bridge district council
as a hard standing when they carried out
works to brimley
brook and the western half of the site
has a gravel
surface over it it has previously had
consent granted
for parking of cars in association with
the trinity school nursery which was
here but is now
vacant and when i visited the site i
have in the past in
just one vehicle parked on the western
half of the site
and the site's covered in low level
vegetation
um as part of the application it is
proposed
to provide a pedestrian walkway from
the site uh southwest corner of the site
um along the boundary with trinity lodge
and
on to buckerage road further south than
the application site
the reason for this being is there's no
footpaths along
uh this part of buckerridge road and it
would allow pedestrians
um closer access to the footpaths which
are
further south
so i have some photographs of the site
this shows the mature trees here along
the boundary
um to trinity school and this is
um the access point into the site and
you can see that it
this part of the site here has a gravel
surface on it
so this is looking from the site this is
into towards the root
uh well this is looking south this is
oak beer house here
and this is five ferndale road and as
you can see when i visited the site
there was a car parked on it
uh and this is looking uh slightly
further to the east of the site so you
can see that half of the site has the
gravel surface
and the other half um doesn't
and there is actually a stream that runs
through between the two halves of the
site
this is at five the rear of five
ferndale road from the site
and you can see the stream here that
runs uh
bisects the center of the site
and this is number 11 ferndale road
from the site and this is from the site
looking towards
number 13 fern ferndale road
and this plan shows you that the
levels on the site drop from the level
of the access track
towards the south and
these are the photographs of the access
onto bucker ridge road you can see this
part is um
this is the access here and it it's uh
tarmacked
here and
this is looking from further up the hill
this is uh convent lodge which is in
uses flats
here and the access is also used by
trinity school as part of their one-way
system
so following refusal of a previous
application
for four dwellings which was refused
by members amongst other things for not
making effective use of the site
the application before you today is for
the construction of 12 flats
which will be in two buildings you can
see the buildings in the the gray areas
each building to contain six flats
and this gives us more detail about the
proposal
so um within each building
there will be an undercover area where
there will be
six car parking spaces and
uh then there are two additional open
air
open parking spaces in this location
so making 14 spaces to serve
the 12 flats in addition
there are cycle stands covered cycle
stands
proposed here and here for each block
with sufficient space for two cycles
per flat there's a bin store area
proposed here
this area is designed to be
of sufficient scale so that a refuse
vehicle can turn
um here
and what i should point out to you that
with the parking spaces the parking
spaces at the end of the blocks
have an additional 900 millimeters
either side of them
to uh provide more accessibility
for less mobile people um so you can see
just
here here here and here these are
these are wider spaces and they are
what's known as
m42 compliant which is defined as
accessibility and adaptive
and the two spaces here are designed to
be m43 compliant which means they are
suitable for
a wheelchair user
two of the flats would be for affordable
dwellings or social rent
flats
so this plan is quite helpful uh it
shows you that a communal garden area
is proposed in the center of the site
uh and a walkway along the southern part
of the site with
a bridge over this over the stream
and this is the block plan and i'll just
point out to you that the building line
is staggered along the south elevation
to provide some articulation and relief
to to the building
the main access points will be uh from
the north
from the track um for the flats
apart from the two ground floor flats uh
on the south in blockay
which will their access will be through
here and
coming through uh to the south and
that's because of the root protection
area from the trees
which has implications for the
foundations
of um of the building and it means they
can't take a staircase
down to to the entrance level
uh the exist it's proposed to finish the
existing
uh tracking gravel
and with a 1.5 meter path alongside
the buildings so i've put the
cgi elevations in uh because i i think
it's much easier to understand
than just when you first faced with the
plans
so the two blocks would be two stories
from the north side and uh they would
step down uh the level drop on the site
and would be
three stories from their south side
and this is this is looking from the
south side
so you can see that the top floor of the
build of the blocks would be set back
and there would be a balcony area
on the on the top floor here there are
also small balcony areas in the central
element
of of the buildings
and i'll go through the floor plans
because of the
level changes you effectively you come
in on what the
applicant has described as the first
floor plan so the entrance is the same
level as the parking area
um and then you would have uh
the flats will be on each of the three
floors
so this is the lower ground floor where
i explained that the entrances
are from the southern side
and this is the second floor and you can
see that
uh as i said earlier that the the
building line is
set back and there's quite a large uh
terrace area
uh on either side and they're two two
flats
per floor and these are the elevation
plans
the elevation at the bottom is what is
the north elevation that you would see
from the entrance track
with the undercover parking um
within the building and this is the the
main entrance
and this is the elevation uh facing the
south which we
have seen on the cgi image
and um elevations from of the sides of
the building and here you can see how
the buildings would um
work with the topography and step down
the top
step down the gradients on the site
so the floor plans for block b which
is the easternmost block uh are very
similar
um the the main difference being that
uh the entrance to the what
you would think is the ground floor but
they're described as first floor by the
agent
uh flats can be accessed from here they
will also be able to be accessed
um from the south but that but all six
flats can be accessed from the northern
side
in block b and uh did you see
um they're very similar design
and uh on this plan this is the second
floor plan
and uh it's indicated on here that an
obscure glazed uh
screen will be put along the side here
this is the side adjacent to 13
ferndale road and there will also be a
privacy screen
1.7 meters high along here
and these are the elevations for block b
just uh similar so i was just showing
you the
the privacy screen on the side of block
b
and uh and the obscure glazed
uh panel as well
so these elevations show how the
buildings will fit in with the context
of the existing buildings on the site so
this is
a 13 ferndale road here and this is
convent lodge here so you can see that
the height
of the proposed uh buildings will be
lower than
convent lodge and will actually be lower
than 13 ferndale road
and this elevation is is looking from
the south so it shows you the
relationship with
oakbeer house and five ferndale road
which because the ground levels are
lower there the proposed blocks of flats
will be higher
and again uh these show the
the side elevations so they're quite
helpful to you
in showing uh what happens with the
ground levels
so the application site is at higher
level than the level of the buildings
to to the south
and these are the site sections what's
interesting here
to point out to you is that the
applicant is proposing to increase the
ground levels at the rear
of um at the rear of the flats and uh
depending on where you are on the site
that that level of increase is slightly
higher
and it's also helpful you can see that
the the lowest level of the buildings
is is roughly equivalent to the first
floor
of the properties to the south
and more details on the sections and
also we have finished floor levels
so i've put this in because i think this
helps you understand
uh how the building works in three
dimensions and how the how the levels
work
and more images
so uh now this is some more information
about building design that the applicant
submitted
where they have demonstrated that they
have looked at the
cues from the established development in
the area
and picked up things such as projecting
bay structures
which obviously this is a modern
development
but they they have tried to respect that
and include that in the development in
terms of the projecting structure here
and they've also looked at introducing
this is called
brickwork panels which breaks up the
elevations and adds interest
and variety to the building um and
um also brickwork detailing along uh the
top face of the building
and that's an illustration of the
standing seam
metal uh that that's proposed for the
top floor of the building
so i've included this to show you that
part of the roof is proposed to be a
green roof now in in this image it does
show photovoltaic
panels on the roofs of the buildings and
when i've asked the applicant about that
they've said it's not their intention to
install photovoltaic
volt tonic panels at the moment
but um there is a potential for them to
be installed on the roof
in the future
so this gives us a little bit more uh
information
about um the building design and
one of the key issues which i'm sure you
have picked up is
the relationship of the building to
neighbouring properties and
particularly in terms of intervisibility
and in order to address this the
applicant has included measures
such as on the projecting balconies on
the south sides of the building
there are uh slatted screens on
either side which narrow you can see
here
they're intended to narrow the outlook
when you're inside
the flats uh towards
uh the properties to the south and at
roof level
there is a 1.1 meter high wall and then
a planter as well
which will uh restrict um the view
from the top from the second floor flat
so that the outlook is
is more in front of you rather than
looking down
and then also at first floor level
the windows facing south the lower
panels will be obscure glazed
so the applicant has done a lot of work
on inter visibility
and there's a lot of slides which
i will go through fairly quickly if
members want to go back and have a more
detailed look at them then
please let me know but this uh this plan
is
is illustrating the outlook from those
central
um windows which is restricted by the
slatted screens
on either side so that the outlook will
be the dark areas of the blue and the
green and not the light areas
which is concentrated with the outlet
going between the gaps between the
properties to the south
rather than allowing a peripheral ves
vision and this is an image that the
applicant submitted
of of the slatted screen to
which would restrict the outlook
so uh here the uh
applicant has done a lot of analysis
about
the outlook from the windows on the
proposed flats
so what you are seeing here where it's
dark blue
that is the area that is what you will
see from the windows
and where it is a lighter blue that will
be obscured so in this instance we're
looking at
um bedroom window whether the
lower part of the window is obscure
glazed so you can only look at you only
get a vision
looking out horizontally and not looking
out uh
down and this is uh they've done a lot
of analysis
of the relationship of the buildings to
the buildings
to the to the existing buildings to the
south
so on the on these plans it shows you
where they've taken these lines uh where
they've taken these views
and this is the analysis and um the
distance and
the distances are they've worked on the
basis of these
the end of the cones are 21 meters
which is a general accepted distance
that
uh 21 meters between
facing windows is is generally
considered not to result
in a loss of privacy and to be an
acceptable standard
so uh i will i'll carry on through these
because there is quite a lot of them
and uh when um i was on the
site visit with members i talked about
uh i was in discussions with the
applicant about
uh the relationship from the ground
floor and the treatment along the
boundary and i'd just like to confirm
that the applicant is now showing a 2.2
meter high
boundary fence and the the green line
here is 2.4 meters
high of planting because um
because of the difference in levels
we need to also consider the impact of
intervisibility from the ground floor
of the proposed flats
so and the green colors are the
relationship from
block b which is the eastern block
so in terms of intervisibility what i
wanted to say
is that um having looked at the analysis
the applicant
submitted the relationship to the
properties to the south does fall short
of the expected levels particularly in
sections
d and h uh the analysis submitted by the
applicant
is all based on uh the relationship
when people are inside the building
obviously
we need to be aware that it's possible
to stand on the central balcony area and
it would be
you would be able to look down to the
properties to the south
and similarly that there would be more
into visibility
if you stand on the balconies at second
floor
level so what i've written in my officer
report is
i think it's borderline as to whether or
not
the relationship between the buildings
constitutes an unacceptable level of
privacy between
the properties what i've considered
is that the western half of the site
could be used as a car park
which uh allowed you can see from the
photographs at the beginning of the
presentation does allow views into the
rear of the properties
uh there's also a tree screen along the
boundary with number five
ferndale road which i think probably has
the worst relationship
between the buildings um
and i haven't in my recommendation to
you
i haven't included uh loss
of privacy as a reason for refusal if
members
disagree with this i think it would not
be unreasonable
for you to impose this as a reason for
refusal if
you feel that the development is
unacceptable
so this this slide shows the area of the
root protection uh from the trees to the
north which you can see
impacts as i said earlier on the design
of the
stairwell in block a
and if we look here you can see that
the structure of block a is cantilevered
over the root protection area
in order that the foundations don't
affect the
root protection area
and in the report
to members the original report which was
written in december
there were concerns about there's an
area of decking which
is in the southeast corner which was
going to be a raised area of decking
because it's above an attenuation tank
uh the applicant has now dropped that
by 700 millimeters and um
it is uh more or less at uh existing
ground level and a two meter fence
is proposed along the eastern boundary
of the site
this is a soft landscaping plan and you
can see here that
the stream is incorporated as a positive
feature as part of the
communal gardens to serve the
development
so um
the highway engineer uh has recommended
refusal to the
application and um following
this consultation the applicant has
worked with his
highway advisor to
suggest ways in which to overcome the
highways issue
and the applicant has suggested that
they could put a build out
to the north of the
which would restrict the width of the
carriageway you can see here
the restrict the width of the buckeridge
road to
4 meters which would enable greater
visibility
for vehicles exiting from the
application site
the application the applicants also
submitted a road safety
audit the council's highway engineer
has reviewed the proposal for the build
out
and he feels that this isn't acceptable
and would lead to conditions of danger
on the highway
what he says is that in his view the
build-out will force vehicles traveling
down the hill
to move to the wrong side of the road
without having a view
of the vehicle traveling up the hill
and in his view the build-out itself
would become a hazard in the highway
with potential vehicle strikes
so in terms of highway the devon county
highway engineer's position is
that although the increase in trips
from the development will be 2.5
greater than if the site was used as the
approved car park
the trip uh distribution would be out
through would be throughout the day
and the year not just at school times
and in his view this is a significant
and tangible change to the trip
generation pattern
uh without the build out the visibility
from the junction is 16.3 meters
southbound
and only to the edge of the junction
northbound and the required distance
for this road which has a 30 mile an
hour limit
is 43 meters in either direction
in his view the site fails to provide a
safe route for traffic
leaving the site and maneuvering onto
buckeridge road
so reference is made in the officer
report to the requirements in
the nppf um that development should
provide a safe and suitable access
and that development should only be
prevented or refused on highway grounds
if there would
be an unacceptable impact on highway
safety
in my view i think the highways issue
is also finally balanced the council has
granted consent for a 15 space car park
on the site there was no highway
objection to the previous application
for four dwellings
on the site and in fact uh
when the applicant submitted
pre-application inquiry
for development on this site there was
no highway objection erased at that time
there are no records of accidents
occurring at this junction
the junction is already used by trinity
school
and convent lodge
and so there are arguments
on either side in this case it's my
opinion
our opinion that we should take the
technical advice of the
qualified highway engineer from the
county and
uh the recommendation to you is that
uh the application is refused on highway
grounds there are other reasons
for refusal and i'll get to those uh in
a little bit
so this is a sweat path analysis that
the applicant submitted
uh relating to how larger vehicles will
access the site
if the build out was provided
and uh when we were on the member site
visit
the issue of land ownership was raised
and there is an area of unregistered
land within the application site
along the northern boundary um which is
part of the access track
so the applicant has uh submitted the
correct certificate now it wasn't with
the original application but we have
certificate c
and uh the correct advertisement has uh
been placed in the mid devon advertiser
and the tim must paste and we haven't
received
any representations following uh posting
of this
uh that's an example of the privacy
screen that the applicant's proposing to
use
so in conclusion i just have a few
points
which um i would say that uh
the previous reason that members refused
the application on the site
one of one of the issues was that the
development of four dwellings did not
make effective use of the site
i think that this proposal responds well
to
to that issue um by increasing the
density of development on the site
the proposal is a good quality
development
there are improvements to biodiversity
on the site um and the parking within
the building
means that it's possible to provide an
attractive area of open space
for residents rather than just a sea of
parking around the building which
commonly happens in
developments the application site is a
sustainable location within walking
distance of the town centre
the development is sustainable it
provides two parking spaces per flat
their
wheelchair compliant parking spaces and
all 12 car parking spaces will have
electric uh
charging points
uh four of the apartments would be to
m42 standard which is uh
the adaptable standard and two being
capable of being
adapted to the m43 which is for
wheelchair
users standard there's social benefits
in terms of providing additional housing
on the site and their economic benefits
from the development in terms of the
construction and long-term benefits of
occupants
spending with local businesses um
but uh in this instance we have to weigh
the materially positive benefits against
the specialist
technical highway advice that we've had
that the proposal will
result in an unsafe access with
resulting unacceptable impact
on the highway safety
and in this instance as i said earlier
that
i think that significant weight should
be given to the advice from the highway
engineer
so the the first recommendation for
refusal to you
is on highway grounds the other two
recommendations are the reasons for
refusal
relate to the fact that we don't have a
section 106 agreement
at the moment to secure the provision of
the affordable housing and the habitat
mitigations payments but
those those two could be secured if if
needed
it is simply good practice to include
them in the reasons for refusal
because there is no completed 106 at the
moment
so that is the recommendation to you
which is
what is on the update sheet that was
circulated on friday and that's the end
of my presentation thank you
right thank you helen okay
if we could now turn to the public
speakers i've got the two
members of the public listed um
i've got mrs hartley down on my list
first and then
i have john perkins down second so if i
could ask
mrs hartley please it's a major
application so it's
up to five minutes for each and both are
objectors
this is hartley let's see if i can see
on screen
okay i can see yeah can you unmute
please let's make a heartbeat
that's it right okay so you've got five
minutes and um
and it starts when you when you start
speaking
good morning i'm christine hartley i
live at willowdean
ferndale road i hope to represent the
most important views
of my neighbours i would like to
emphasize firstly
how much the threat of this development
has affected the health and well-being
of nearby residents myself included
one of the most distressing issues for
all of us
is the overwhelming feeling of loss of
prison privacy
resulting from this development the
dominating and
overbearing nature of the buildings as
proposed
will have a severely damaging effect on
the enjoyment
of our homes and gardens that loss
of air and light quality will bring
about a profound
and lasting detrimental change
the plans drawings and technical data
submitted by the developers seemed to
bear no relation to the actual size
topography and location of the site my
daughter likened it to the proposed
uh in mary poppins bag not constrained
by flag
however the reality is that the blocks
and access areas will cover
almost the whole site and in many
instances
be within a few meters of established
homes
many ground floor residents will like me
be hard-pressed to see the sky from
their rear
windows once the three-story blocks are
built
the monolithic blocks will dominate the
surroundings
the brick glass metal and slate features
together with the intrusive and
overhanging balconies and territory
are completely out of keeping with the
area
this lack of sensitive design only adds
to the
sense of loss felt by residents at the
distraction of a much valued green space
and the natural life it supported
but perhaps of greatest concern is the
effect of the substantial
increased traffic flow which will
inevitably caused by the 12
pound additional household the single
lane track
currently serving convent lodge trinity
school and addison lodge
cannot possibly cope with the increase
in cars delivery vehicles etc
no passing space is possible and all
users
pass within feet of the windows and
front doors
of the flats that convent lodge the
entrance to buckwheat road is already
extremely difficult and dangerous
and the possibility of serious accidents
is now a reality the proposal to build
the build-out
seems demented in our view
once completed this development together
with the proposed six houses at trinity
lodge
we'll add 18 new homes built on the on
small and suitable sites
to an area already suffering traffic
congestion
and parking problems we are all aware
that the extreme weather events are
multiplying
the development will add to the
increasing local problem
of water runoff and flooding properties
in ferndale road
continued to suffer runoff incident and
a real threat of flooding
the proposal to divert surface water
runoff into the coal bit which runs
through the site and then
underground to ferndale road is
dangerous
impractical and short-sighted who will
monitor and maintain this water course
pressure is already causing damage to
drives and road services
this will increase with the development
the cramming of the site will produce
more noise pollution
and disturbance for all the proposal
seeks to maximize the number of units to
the detriment of all residents
these will be cramped unsatisfactory
owned
into the future the proposal is over
developed
it will overshadow surrounding houses
and is overbearing the design is
intrusive
and out of keeping in the area a
balanced
urban rural environment will be lost
access is profoundly inadequate will add
to current traffic problems
and is potentially dangerous the
problems
already it's being experienced with
water runoff
and flooding will be increased and no
proper provision
to alleviate these concerns has been
provided
the potential provision of social unit
especially the adopted ones is very very
welcome
but the site access issues may prove to
be
a hazard to these residents
in conclusion the proposal is over
developed
overcrowded ill-considered and in the
wrong place
thank you thank you okay can i now
ask can you mute your speaker please mrs
hartley
thank you and uh john perkins on the
screen if
if you'd speak now please again you have
up to five minutes
if you're done mute please
can can you unmute mr perkins
can you hear me right now yeah okay
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to
you and the community members this
morning thank you um
some key points about this land need to
be perfectly made clear
all of this land was a fully functional
vegetable garden literally maintained by
the london notre dame
school for over a century but sadly
fellaini did decline once this school
was taken over by trinity school
um about a couple of decades ago i did
more and more
at least half if not more than half of
this land still remains the greenfield
site there's never been a car park
some years ago the other half of the
land did receive temporary planning
permission
to be regarded as a temporary car park
following construction of a trap to a
nearby culvert on behalf of the local
authority
however this use never materialized and
the planning commission was not renewed
so it's never been used as a car park
trinity school suddenly suddenly then
sold the land to
bunny homes who immediately
devastatingly fell a whole side of a
long avenue of big mature trees on one
side which sadly
we didn't have the wick to make sure i
had a tree preservation order but as
soon as the
wheat they bought the property they felt
all these trees and destroyed one half
of an avenue of trees
and that itself has had an impact upon
the flooding potential of the land since
then
the truth is this land has never been
used probably as a car park
certainly never to the point of
accommodating 15 vehicles as is
claimed by the developer and their
consultant engineers it's quite shocking
therefore
to see them try to use this to
perpetuate the myth that the junction of
the truck with bubbly droid could
accommodate that volume of traffic
some of my neighbors are overlooked and
are able to testify this is the case
they've
we've watched this land there's never
been more than a couple of vehicles used
at any one time
this is not to discuss the track but at
least from buckridge road to the rear of
my house
and those of my neighbors at 15 1719
ferndale road this track was originally
built to facilitate
a facility access to the back of our
house i have found this victorian house
built in the 1880s and that track was
built to facilitate
access to the back of our house to
deliver coal and all the goods
we've suddenly haven't got uh proof that
they're just there for our purpose
that's what i was there for before even
the school was built
so it seems wrong that the bunny home
should assume
ownership of that in order to make a
rather large track down there and have
access to it when we challenge that
and see it's totally wrong they should
have access to that roadliner
my neighbours are grateful that some of
the planning committee came to visit the
site some months ago
those who didn't tell me to recognize
how steep the track is up through
buckley drone
some of you may also realize how
dangerous the junction the track is with
buck bridge road
i have to negotiate this junction nearly
every day and it's very tricky to say
the least
and if you do it in a vehicle you see
it's even worse if you just stand by it
or look at the photographs of the
provider this morning
one was surely agree with a local view
of the local waste disposal operatives
that would be impossible to collect
waste from this site
and we would say that's the same for any
private companies too indeed the
developer's latest proposal to use
private
wasteless photo contractors possess all
sorts of problems and who would place
this years ahead
if and when occupants refuse to use them
and also join your vision hopefully you
will notice how terribly how to keep in
the debris drawings
these flats would be how to keep them
with our current situation here
i haven't read the design the design
statement
from the developers it's quite shocking
to see how far this is in reality
i must say that to read that care has
been given to me to get overbearing on
neighborhood
properties or architectural form
materials will blame with the character
of
architecture locally it's quite shocking
they should actually say that nothing be
further from the truth
i didn't even wonder whether the author
actually visited the site
this land is surrounded by victorian
quality victorian edwardian buildings
and the design and appearance of these
proposed flats would have such an
adverse impact on the surrounding area
one issue that's causing as much anguish
and mental health is
issues with residents is how the
developers are seeking to maximize any
opportunity
provide sea views to prospect perfective
purchases
just maximizing their wealth the
developers wealth and our mental health
created about how much would be
overlooked and suffer the intrusion of
noise pollution
these flats are too big and overbearing
and i've asked through plans to show
the views from the balconies and the
roof terraces none has been provided
this is again some sort of they're
trying to delude themselves saying
there's no impact upon being overlooked
would be terribly overlooked because if
people stood on those balconies the roof
terraces
they can look straight into my house
into my daughter's bedrooms into my
kitchen diner onto my terrace
and a complete intrusion of my privacy
and it is affecting our mental health
already thinking about how bad this will
be
it's a complete sham the fact that
they're saying this i have no intrusion
about our privacy
it's disgraceful they should actually
try and get away with it
i could go on i'm sorry i'm a bit
nervous and this whole thing here is
so wrong we want this land now to be a
community asset at least half of that
should stay we want to return it to
community asset to make it a charity
to make it a local community where you
can show that use it
so show local school children the
importance of soil health
and about the importance of healthy food
and that should be returned to
a community asset to make it a nice
garden again and we work the developers
is their benefit as well they get good
tax relief on
on making sure that they work with the
charity to return this to
how it should be into a good community
asset with no building on it at least on
the part there's not been a car
chair that's terrible okay thank you
thank you mr perkins
time's up so can you now put your mute
back on please thank you
okay right um well we have had a site
inspection so there are members who
have been out to have a look at it
previously i don't have
i haven't had a request from the two
ward members to come in and speak and
haven't seen them
in the uh people on the screen so would
anyone like to lead off i will if
if nobody else is is keen to speak
right i've got oh council mcgregor i
thought perhaps you might wish to come
in
and then councillor hook councilman
you're muted andrew
council mcgregor you're muted
that's better sorry about that thank you
thank you um
just wanted to to point out first of all
that council reading is actually um
working at the moment so you couldn't
attend the the planning committee
meeting
right um i'm i've sat through some some
very interesting present
sales presentations uh in my time and
that that was
possibly one of the most significant
that i've seen for quite some time
um i am concerned though that um several
of the the drawings and
and plans and pictures that we've been
presented with
actually don't give us the full picture
the line of trees that is presented on
for instance the block plan
that line of trees runs all of the way
to the gatehouse
or to the gateway of trinity school
running past that very narrow entrance
way
and those those trees do present
a significant um impact on
whether or not a vehicle can get in and
out of that site
that is more than three and a half
meters high because they grow out
from the the path over the path
um narrowing it to less than half its
width at two meters
height which is my my own height um
so there's a little bit of concern about
the actual presentation of their
also there was no pictures of the the
reason why
the um waste um
recommendation was for refusal because
of the camber
of the entrance road so i was a bit
surprised that we didn't see any
pictures of that either the waste
were particularly concerned about
vehicles coming around the corner with
the camber of the road
and bouncing the top of their vehicles
off convent lodge which would cause
damage
to the vehicle as well as the the lodge
itself
and also also puts um
people coming out of convent lodge at
risk because the vehicle is passing
literally past the
bottom of the the front step
um in terms of the actual um site itself
i'll come back to the i'll come back to
the measurements for the roadway in a
second or two
my overriding um view of the the um
the development is that it does cause
significant loss of privacy
for three houses um
one of which uh number 13 the
the loss of privacy the only
justification that they've got for
trying to
to reduce the loss of privacy there is
to put a 1.7 meter screen
across part of the balcony um but if you
stand forward of that one meter 1.7
meter screen
you've got full view into number 13's
bedrooms and
down into the kitchen as well and i
think that that is a significant loss of
privacy and i don't think that has been
emphasized
nearly enough as to what kind of impact
that will have
on on existing residents um
in terms of the the um the design
the track um the significant route work
there so
it would need to be it hasn't been
explained that
the track would need to be raised to
actually be implemented to avoid
damaging the roots because the roots are
inter
mingled with existing roots for the
trees that mr perkins mentioned
that were felled on the opposite side of
the track from
those with the tpo and they are all
intermingled so there would be
an issue there and there was no
explanation that the track would need to
be raised
um and also but my understanding and
having been up
back up to the site and taking
measurements of the entrance way
it it fails to meet the standards set by
the fire brigade
the width of the the entrance way is
short of the the width minimum width for
gate posts
and curbs that are set by the fire
brigade and the turning circle required
for a tender is 16.8 meters
and looking at the the um plans and
drawings
i don't think that that's available to a
fire tender or a ladder
should either be required at that site
and that that comes under um
regulation b5 in the building
regulations i believe so there are
significant issues with
access there are significant issues with
overlooking and privacy
um you know i'm those those are the key
issues for me
i think lots of privacy has a main
criteria
um and the the the the fact that devon
highways and the waste have both said
that it's an impractical unsafe entrance
way
into the site thank you very much thank
you councillor hook
thank you um i i didn't go on the site
visit for this application but have
previously been to the site um for the
previous application so i do know the
site
um i was just gonna ask for some
clarification
really um at this stage um
on in the report i mean it was mentioned
about some planning updates that we were
sent on friday i
checked through my emails and i i didn't
receive planning updates so
maybe i'm missing some information but
on the report we're given four reasons
for refusal the last one did
relate to um a reason related to
disposal of refuse and the canberra of
the entrance road
and that hasn't just been that's been
taken off
the list of reasons for refusal that was
just presented to us
and i'm not clear on why that was
because that did seem to be
a significant reasons for refusal
because it won't just be waste vehicles
it will be other vehicles
that need to gain access that council
mcgregor mentioned
including removals lorries etcetera um
so can i just have some clarification on
whether there are three reasons
or four reasons for refusal right the
update sheet is published on the
public agenda site um
i gained mine from there so i'm not
quite sure about the members having
received it
directly themselves or not but i've read
it and there are
the three reasons it gives details at
the waist
uh it's a private contractor in a 3.5
ton
high sided tipper that um would take
the waste in order to be a smaller
vehicle
but perhaps helen are you able to or or
um chris advise on the
update sheet i mean it's more committee
section
perhaps helen so
i can talk to you about uh waste
and um councillor mcgregor is correct
that the
council's uh waste department
raised an objection to the application
uh because of the camber on the road
adjacent
to convent lodge uh saying that
they would not be able to collect the
waste from the flats
so when the original report was written
we'd we didn't have um an acceptable
proposal from the applicant as to
how waste could be disposed of from the
site which is why there was a
there was a waste reason for refusal
subsequent to
write in the main officer report uh
as councillor haynes has said the
applicant
put a proposal to us that a private
contractor
could uh collect the waste and
they have provided evidence that the
private contractor
can use a 3.5 ton high sided tipper as
as you said to collect the waste which
is a smaller vehicle
which would be able to access the site
and they've specified
the waste transfer station that the
waste would be taken to and if you look
on the website
it uh they aim to recycle 90
of the waste at the waist transfer
station
so having considered that the point that
i made in the
um update sheet is uh
and um there was a point that was raised
earlier as well
is about ensuring that uh that
uh form of disposal of waste is secured
in perpetuity and i've
spoken to the council solicitor about
this and uh she's satisfied that we
could include
if members were minded to approve the
application could approve a clause
in the section 106 agreement uh
um relating to sizes of vehicles
uh that would access the site
so in our in our opinion the applicant
has
put forward a proposal in which waste
could be satisfactorily addressed and
therefore
we have removed the recommendation that
we include that as
a reason for refusal and
the applicant i know the applicant is
also looking at whether it would be
possible
to regrade the uh entrance raid adjacent
to convent lodge
and actually remove the camber which
would
then resolve the issue about access for
the waste vehicle thank you i hope that
helps
yeah i i would feel uncomfortable myself
about the whole
precedent issue there but i don't think
we need to dwell on that today
councilman did you wish to come back now
uh i i i can wait for later and then
others speak okay
um i've got councillor bullet next i
think
good morning thank you on the site visit
i
was impressed with the information that
the officer was able to point out while
she was looking at the
the plans and also recognize
bring a modern building in any structure
in any location
is going to create differences of
opinion
and i was also pleased that the amount
of work that the developer proposed to
mitigate
some of these sight line problems
however having said all of that
i was still very concerned that there
were going to be oversight
views and that was something that would
cause a problem
certainly caused a problem for me the
access road
that links to the existing building
was also going to be maintained for
access to that
building and yet this application has
got
14 car parking spaces
in total for effectively 20 up to 24
bedrooms
and there are no facilities planned for
visitor car parking
which inevitably means that the access
road is going to be used as a place for
vehicles to park whilst they're visiting
the um
the apartments which is going to cause a
disruption for anybody else seeking to
use the access road
that itself i think is a major problem
and would um indicate that this site is
as its design is over development
and for that reason i was going to say i
made a few
notes uh in the process i mean council
of bulman just mentioned the last one i
was going to mention about
with having 12 flats and only about 14
15 spaces
you could have the possibility of 24 uh
vehicles
um needing to uh go to the site and
like like council blumen said as well um
where
where does the visitors park on that um
overlooking and privacy i think even
with the
screening that has been uh recommended
um
people will still be able to look over
into the gardens and the privacy of the
people there will be impounded on that
and again access into the site is
unsuitable for emergency vehicles
even our own recycling
lorries etc and i i think the
the access into the site off of the buck
bridge road i mean i was quite surprised
the steepness of that road
um obviously and there's a quite a bend
as you're coming out of the site on the
left so i thought it's quite a steep uh
and bend
there coming out to that um
the design i mean is totally out of
character and
not in certainly not in keeping with the
surrounding properties there that's for
sure
and um one last point that mr perkins
mentioned and which i
had written down i think the area would
be very
good to become a community garden um
excellent idea and which would have
would benefit everybody i think in that
area um
but as i say i must admit at the moment
i
i couldn't uh support this application
and say i'll listen to others but um
that's how i feel at the moment so thank
you chair thank you
well i also attended the site visit so
i'll
have a few words to say on it i agree
with the
highways recommended reason for refusal
so
i think that's clear and straightforward
on the immunity and overlooking um
i was concerned about that when i went
to the site visit
the application before us although we've
had the heights of the various
buildings around compared the fact is
this is the
only one with a flat roof building
so in fact you've got the top story
higher
than you would have on the other
buildings and it's that much higher
top story looking down
from the balconies particularly would be
the concern into those other buildings
which would cause that loss of immunity
with overlooking that
i consider to be an issue and a reason
for refusal
um as far as the refuse vehicle is
concerned as i said just now
i'm not um happy with the whole
concept of that but um i can't see that
as a reason for refusal
uh as it currently stands with what's
been put forward in the amendment sheet
so those are my views um it's question
i i would move the recommendation
of refusal with the three reasons
given on the update sheet but i would
add the reason
of loss of immunity with the overlooking
um into neighboring properties so there
would be
those four reasons that i would move as
a reason for refusal and somebody
chair excuse me chair um who's i can't
see you speaking
counselor mcgregor thank you yes um
before we go that i i think it's it's
important to to mention
specifically that this is a significant
impact on privacy
because that is a valid reason for
refusal as well
yes that's that's in my soy community
and
privacy then if you like that's fine
thank you
i missed the privacy bit okay sorry
but it's been seconded by council
natalie so it's just that we've got
something on the table now and we can
obviously move on
in that on that basis right i've got
council bradford next please
thank you chair um i did go on the site
meeting
and i um
agree with everything that's been said
and i couldn't possibly
vote for this i think a community garden
would be a great idea
thank you okay councilman hook
thank you um and as i say i went on the
site this a couple of times ago when it
was the
um proposal for the four houses and
interestingly enough
um we refused that on the basis that we
felt better use could be made at the
site
so i you know feel a bit disappointed
that when we're not being able to come
forward with a scheme that works here
for housing because to me
it's a site that is suited for some form
of housing
development um so i'm saddened that that
we can't seem to make this work or the
the applicant can't seem to make this
work
um but you know i entirely understand
the reasons
um you know for me it is a brownfield
site it's a sustainable location
and it will have would have provided two
affordable flats um
or an affordable housing contribution
one or the other
um but you know it's very rare for devon
county council highways to
object to an application so i don't
think we should take that lightly
we're often pushing them in the other
direction and here they have made an
objection
so i feel it would be really unwise for
us to go against
their objections to this application um
uh i also yeah and i mean in terms of
the waste vehicles to me it's not just
about waste vehicles there will be other
vehicles that want to
access those flats and if it's a problem
for a
waste work it will be a problem for
several other vehicles that might want
to visit those
flats including when people first want
to move in with their
removable vehicles but other emergency
vehicles possibly as well
so that that to me is also a concern
um you know if if the camber could be
conditioned for example then
you know to get rid of the camber and
that could be conditioned in well then
okay but that isn't what's on the table
that isn't what being proposed here
i would say as well that back on the
report in december
um the applicant was um going to be
asked to provide a carbon
calculator um for the development to
show that it
adhered to policy s7 um there hasn't
been any discussion on that so i assume
it hasn't been done
so that's a concern although obviously
the development in itself does appear
to have various good sustainability um
criteria um additions to it
um so you know i would support the
refusal but i'm i am disappointed that
we haven't so far
found a housing scheme that will work on
that site
on the other hand if the community can
make community garden work there
absolutely support that as well um if
that could be
made workable um okay those are my
comments thank you
thank you council mcgregor did you want
to come back or are you you're okay now
okay thank you sorry it was it was just
to add in the the it's i think it's
quite important to bear in mind that
on the entrance way into the site beyond
convent lodge
the first gate posts are 2.3 meters wide
and the second set of gate posts are 2.8
meters wide
the minimum requirement for a fire
tender is 3.1
on on the the recommendations that they
put forward
and between curbs 3.7 meters
with a turning circle of 16.8 this is
actually a health and safety matter as
well
and i you know i think it's quite
important to emphasize
that that is a requirement that's set by
the fire brigade
for safe um communities
okay thank you so i mean as a technical
thing they'd have to overcome
were they to get planning permission
that that's also there as well
okay nobody else has indicated they wish
to speak so the motion before us
was for refusal for the three reasons
outlined on the
update sheet and the fourth reason for
the immunity
overlooking loss of privacy and the
balconies
principally into the existing dwellings
around
so if we could go to the vote on that
then please so the
motion is for refusal so if you wish to
refuse
you should vote for okay chris
you take that then please thank you
chair councillor bradford
bulovant councillor clarence
councillor cochlear councillor cox
councillor hayes moore councillor hook
councillor jeffrey councillor kurzweil
four councillor mcgregor
or councillor nuttall whoa
councillor natalie four councillor patch
port councillor goodman bradbury
four and councillor haynes
that's unanimous chair okay that's karen
15 minutes two months so that's
been refused i'll take one more because
it's a shorter one now
no public speakers before we go uh for
any
comfort break so the next item on the
agenda
is the um south view
for stockton avenue dawlish
as i say there's no members of the
public wish to speak on this
so if i could ask ros eastman please to
give us the presentation on this one
thank you chair just uh bear with me
while i sort my
paperwork
there we go okay
so this application um as we've been
hearing is before you today is it
it's an application submitted on behalf
of the councillor
uh it's an application for a replacement
conservatory
um uh removal of a first floor rear
extension and reinstatement of a window
um and uh construction of a veranda
area and the property
is in uh of stockton hills
are you are you giving us a screen view
of this because
presentation because i'm not seeing it
at the moment my apologies i must have
uh forgotten to hit the final button
right yeah no i'd looked away to get
with the agenda from my other screen
now right okay carry on okay uh bear
with me a second um
okay can you are you seeing my video of
all of you
now at the moment have i got the wrong
screen no no i've yeah
i can see your presentation that that's
it yeah no okay
no i've got your agenda a copy now oh
bear with me honestly i thought i had
the skills
it normally works so well
that's it that's the one yeah okay
right unfortunately i can't say it there
we go
there we go move that out of the way so
um yeah
i was just describing the proposal to
you and then uh
moved on to this slide which shows you
the property here
subject property which is accessed off
stockton hill in dallas
and as you can see the property is this
is the front
property to the south so it is set well
back in
in the site in terms of its orientation
and alignment
on the site and the properties to the
rear
these properties here are uphill
from from the dwelling in question so
the site layout
at the moment you can see
that the the existing conservatory wraps
around the eastern side of the property
and protruding the front again like i
was saying because the the
um garden to the rear is actually
relatively narrow
um the the larger area of the the garden
or amenities faces
is to the front and side of the property
and the proposal is for a
modernized sun room conservatory
structure
to the eastern side of the property in
particular
the reinstatement of a window here and
then some other minor changes to the
property as well
so this photograph shows the front of
the dwelling this is from a 2017
proposal that we had here
uh i'll show you the front of the
dwelling at the moment in a in in a
second that
this helpfully shows the window that it
is proposed
to be reinstated now having
had this conversation with the chair
yesterday and my understanding is that
this requires planning permission
because it has been blocked up
so we're reinstating the window so
ordinarily
side windows at first floor level
require planning permission unless they
are obscure glazed
but you can see here that this window is
a secondary window serving the bedroom
whose main window would be
this bay window to the front of the
property you can also see there's an
existing
window at first floor to the rear of the
property
and then on the right hand side here you
can see the existing
um brown colored framing for the
existing conservatory
and at the moment this is a view from
the other side of the front of the
property with scaffolding that's having
some work done to its roof at present
and you can see the conservatory area
here wrapping around the
side of the front and side of the
property the terrace to the front
and continues wrapping around
though so this is the view to the east
of the neighbor to the east
you can see the existing relationship
and separation distance there
from the um conservatory and raised
terrace area
that's the elevation to the rear
and then that's the west again and
that's the 2017 image and
currently with the scaffolding up
and then lastly there's the garage area
which is in the process of being
reinstated modernized so
one of the key considerations here is
the impact of the additional window
at the first floor level on the neighbor
to the west and you can see here that
the neighbor to the west has a high
level
small window themselves as well as the
bay window to the front of the property
and this next image here shows nicely
the relationship between the two
properties
uh including the reinstated window
at first floor level the boundary
treatment in between and then the
the side elevation here of the neighbor
to the west
so we have a couple of plans um showing
the existing ground floor plan
again with the conservatory wrapping
around the property
and showing how that is um replaced by
uh this more angular modern
sunroom conservatory structure and then
at the first floor level
um there is a small area
of extension being removed as part of
the overall works
here just this uh small change here
so the um that's the existing southern
elevation
with the uh conservatory here to the
east and then
the new sunroom feature
being instated on on largely a similar
footprint
and again from the side elevation you
can see
the small extension to the rear that's
being removed
and the sun room structure that's coming
around
wrapping around the side
and then from the other end of the
property
thank you very much chair that was all i
wanted to show
and when i looked on the file this
morning there were no additional updates
from any members of the public yeah
there was something in the
um um supplement
that sent out or was out on friday the
additional works was that the valance
windows i don't did you mention that yes
so the update sheet um uh
i mentioned that there had been an
additional representation
received raising concerns in relation to
works that don't form part of this
application so that's v lux windows to
the roof at the rear
but they would be permitted development
they're not included in this application
okay thank you right as i said we've got
no public speakers
we don't have a ward member because one
of them is the applicant
um another dualish member has declared
an interest and won't be speaking on
this item or voting
uh so i don't seem to have anyone from
dawlish but i have got now
um somebody's put their hand up um so
that's uh council bullivan please
can i move approval i set out please
thank you
is that seconded yes segmented by
uh councillor nuttall thank you uh yeah
i
wouldn't add anything myself i having
well i would add
i obviously looked at it with the
planning offices
as she intimated and i don't see any
issues with the
the window looking at what's in the
neighboring property in the distances so
and i'm
entirely content with the conservatory
alterations okay i've got
two others or one other perhaps uh yeah
um council mcgregor thank you chair
um it was just to say on that second
last slide
um that um ross was showing us
there was a um a change in the size and
shape of the window
to the rear above the conservatory
um and i was just wondering why that
wasn't particularly highlighted or
anything
let's have a look there with me while i
just have a look at the images myself
it's only a slight change but it was
just you know it is it is it does
yeah it is a change in the shape um i
think it's uh let me just show you that
image so
that we are uh having a look at the same
thing
my screen share keeps popping up halfway
across can can you see my
this slide yeah you see that thank you
so you can see the existing is this uh
more square shaped window and it's being
replaced by
a more sympathetic um synthetically
proportioned scaled window that ties in
much
much better with the the neighbor and
so i'm not the case officer this
application but i have prepared
for this committee meeting um it would
be my view that you wouldn't need
permission
for a smaller uh
window when you've already got an
existing side first floor window of that
nature so there's no enlargement taking
place
uh and i don't think that that would
need planning permission which is uh
why um i would anticipate it hasn't been
included in the description of
development
and why i didn't focus on it here so
it's being reduced in size
and it's an existing window so in the
same way you don't need permission to
change a first floor window to a door
you don't need permission to replace
windows
because the um the immunity impact if
you like is already there
we don't need to address that as part of
this application
thank you thank you thank you okay so it
was moved
uh approval there there were the two
sort of standard conditions given
in the recommendation um for this one
the three-year time limit and the um
agreed plans so i presume the
proposer and second are content with
those conditions
uh council event i'm content to accept
the recommendations
thank you and second down
okay i can't remember who it was but
nowhere else
i'm happy with the recommendations yeah
okay right in which case there's no one
else indicated to speak so if we could
go to the vote on that so the vote is
for
approval uh chris please
thank you chair councillor bradford
councillor bellevant four councillor
clarence
councillor colclough paul councillor cox
councillor hayes councillor hook
councillor councillor kurzweil
or councillor mcgregor
or councillor nussell
councillor natalie four councillor patch
or and councillor haynes
that's you know his chair yes you're
giving me a very good time this morning
difficult ones okay that's that's been
approved then
um and as i indicated earlier i think
we'd take a comfort
break now so i make it um something in
the region of 27 minutes too
shall we say we come back for 22 so that
gives you
seven minutes to bring a drink back and
visit okay we'll restart then
so if you could turn off your cameras
please and your microphones
and see you back at 20 22.
mike yeah i've got to take my wife
wife to the doctors so i've got to leave
in 10 minutes so it's probably best if i
back out now
yeah yeah we'll only just have restarted
so
um that's fine okay okay thanks
okay chris you're there
yes jerome are here do you want to
restart the meeting now
yeah i think um it's the time i
indicated so
you can see who's back
so just got councillors clarence hook
and hayes haven't got their cameras on
currently
chair i wonder if councillor hayes has
been having some ah yeah i was gonna say
yeah camera's on yeah he's counsellor
councillor hook
okay i'm supposed to be with us in a
moment because i just got
a couple of things to say i think um
councillor
because lake had to sweep
council kurzweil had to leave earlier
she said and and um
council bullivan also indicated just as
we were
stopping the meeting just now that he
was unable to
uh remain so we got council hook
back and we're ready to go yeah and see
jackie's there
okay to say i've declared an interest
anyway in the next two applications
okay yeah no that's fine no i was just
checking who wasn't with us right okay
in which case then i think um
everyone's back so um we'll continue
so we're on to the um next two
applications for dornerfield
uh nipple pen there is a member of the
public
who is speaking on both applications
that's john phillips who
um chris can we uh
sure that person's admitted please
he's just joining our chair right thank
you
yeah i can see there's a john on the uh
list there we are yet um
yeah if you could mute your microphone
please um
mr phillips
do i invite you to speak shortly
okay thank you right um
so we take the the first application of
these two is the biomass boiler one the
first one on the
agenda 6c and if i could
um introduce taya cotterill who's the
planning officer i think it's the
first time with us at committee so over
to utah to
go through the presentation on the first
application please
thank you chair i'll just share my
screen now
can everybody see that one oh yeah
yeah okay thank you
so just begin by saying there are no
further updates since the officer report
was published
this application seeks full planning
permission for the sighting of two
biomass boilers that are joined
existing shower blocks at dornerfield
camping site
which is located to the north of ipple
pen
the site is set in and around the
immediate setting of the grade two star
listed farmhouse and its associated
buildings
to the east of the site the boilers have
already been constructed
one of the sheds is located 100 meters
to the west
of the listed building and the boiler
shed to the south
shown here cannot be viewed from the
listed building
both sheds are identical in design and
this is the floor plan showing the
internal configuration
of the boiler shed
and view of the elevations so the sheds
feature dual pitched roofs with a metal
flue
and measure 5.2 meters in width 3.2
meters in depth and have a ridge height
of 3 meters
so here's a photograph of the shed which
is the closest to the lifted farmhouse
100 meters to the west and in context
with its associated shower and laundry
block
so that's the shed there shown in the
background
the other shed is located to the in next
to the shower block to the south of the
site
which is close to black cops and is
mainly hidden from view
as it's between its associated shower
block and the boundary hedge of the site
whilst visible both appear subservient
to the shell blocks they are associated
with
and match in terms of reform and
materials
due to the distance of approximately 100
metres between the biomass boiler shed
which is closest to the grade two star
listed farmhouse
and given that the sheds are viewed in
the context of the shower blocks
themselves
it is considered that the proposal does
not result in any any adverse impacts
upon the setting of the listed building
the biomass boilers have been on site
since october 2019
and have been providing hot water to the
shower blocks at the camping site
by a renewable energy source i'll search
the proposal contributes towards
achieving the carbon emissions target
in policy s7 of the local plan and it's
considered
the boiler support our transition to a
low carbon future
it is considered that the proposal does
not result in any adverse immunity or
visual impacts
and therefore it is recommended for
approval thank you
thank you okay so if we could
uh go back and can i now invite uh john
phillips to speak for up to
three minutes which will start when when
you start speaking
yes um can everybody hear me okay yes i
can
thank you thank you chair and members
for allowing me to address
to explain the context of this
application um
back in 2016 the oil fired boilers were
at the end of their
normal life or useful life and so the
decision was taken by the owners of
dornerfield to heavily invest
in renewables and the boilers were
bought at a cost
of approximately a hundred thousand
pounds
um the new boilers could not be
accommodated in the existing boiler
houses as they are physically three
times the size
so the manufacturers provided that
provide the owners
with standard building design which they
stated was covered by committed
development
hence no planning was required three
years later an under
uh rhi and rhi that's renewable heat
incentives which is
a government incentive scheme um
they required either planning
documentation or local
or a local authority letter stating that
they were permitted development
after contacting team bridge planning
department there was a potential of the
two boilers
the two baller houses did in sight did
in fact require plant commission
and therefore this application is the
result of that advice
the two biomass boilers are located
behind each of the existing toilets and
shower blocks of butter meadow
and black rock cops respectively being
enclosed
so i've been enclosed in two separate
timber sheds
uh sorry two sim two timber shed like
structures
both of these buildings are visually
intrusive
and can't be viewed from the wider
caravan part or need any public view
therefore they have minimal if any
physical or visual impact on the site
or surroundings and we support the
officer's recommendation
for approval thank you thank you
okay um well obviously there's no board
member to
speak on this one as they are the
applicant um
i've looked at it myself and can see no
reasons that i wouldn't in any way
question the recommendation
and what i've read so i'd be happy
to move the recommendations set out that
permission be granted
um sorry who was that
second right secondly
um so that's been moved um as set out
permission be granted and it's seconded
council mcgregor yeah sorry just quickly
chair um yeah
normally we remove the speakers to the
waiting room um for this part but
because the speaker's speaking on the
next
application as well staying here if
that's
okay with you that's okay yeah yeah
thank you
okay um sorry councilman mcgregor
yeah it was just to say i've i've been
out to
uh go on the field on a site visit
previously
um and i have to admit i i didn't
actually see either of the biomass
boilers even though
i was probably standing within feet
i mean they are really are not visible
from anywhere unless you're standing
right beside them
um and from the pictures that i've seen
they they look in extremely
good condition well maintained and a
a um complementary design to the shower
blocks themselves i
i really can't see any reason for for a
refusal on this on this at
all okay thank you
right nobody else indicated they wish to
speak
so it's been moved approval
as set out in the agenda so can i ask
chris to go through the vote please
thank you chair um councillor bradford
oh councillor clarence
councillor colclough thor councillor cox
councilman mcgregor or councillor
knuckle
whoa that's a nightly or
councillor patch four councillor goodman
bradbury
four and councillor haynes
that's unanimous chat yeah thank you so
that's uh
that's approved right we can move on
then to the
next application which again it's the
same site
but for um the nine holiday cottages
with access and parking so we have the
public speaker in with us already as
you've indicated
in which case i can go straight back to
taya to take us through the presentation
on this
application please thank you chair
okay so again there are no further
updates since the officer report was
published on this one
this application seeks full planning
permission for the construction of a
courtyard development comprising nine
holiday cottages together with access
and parking
at dornerfield camping site the site is
set in
in and around the immediate setting of
the grade two start listed farmhouse and
its associated outbuildings
and this application seeks to renew the
previous commission allowed
appeal in 2017. this permission has
since expired and the plans shown today
are
identical to the previous permission in
all respects
as a reminder to the site's context the
sighting of its development is within an
existing area known as the orchard
located to the west of the grade 2 star
listed farmhouse
an adjoining walled garden it is
currently used for camping and caravan
pictures and has associated servicing
hookups within the field itself
vehicular access is taken from the
existing hard standing within the site
and the proposed parking area adjoins
the walled garden
individual access to each cottage is
from the courtyard itself
with the rest of the site supposed to be
planted up with fruit trees
the elevations are shown are per the
previous permission
and materials include local rebel stone
rendered block work and weatherball
panels with slate pitched roofs
including solar panel inserts and roof
lights
all windows and doors would be stained
timber
so just a little walk through of the
site so this would be the vehicular
access into the orchard area
you can see the wall guards in there in
the background
this is looking from the access straight
through to the site and you can see one
of the existing shell blocks there in
the background
and again looking towards the wall
garden from the south of the site
and looking from above the site in
context with the grade 2 stylist
farmhouse which is in the background
here
with the adjoining wall garden so in
view of its close proximity to the
listed building
our conservation officer considers
considers that the proposal would result
in some harm on the setting and does
maintain their objection
however it is important to note the
planning history on the site
when coming to a conclusion on the
impact as a reminder there is also a
partial
partially implemented planning
permission dating back to 1989
the seven detached log cabins on the
site
at the time of the 2017 appeal the
inspector concluded that the harm
resulting from the 1989 permission would
be substantial
and found the appeal scheme to be
preferable to that alternative
the proposed development set up today is
identical to that permitted in 2017.
as this permission is still relatively
recent it is not considered that there
have been significant
in-principle changes to the policy
framework or additional case law
that would change the position since
this 2017 permission
and therefore i am recommending approval
of the application subject to conditions
thank okay thank you
right um once again then if um i can
invite
um john phillips up to three minutes on
this application have to
which the officer has already made but
um i just simply didn't put this in
context
um the first application was submitted
in 2010
and was approved and supported by
cambridge district council in english
heritage as a preferable location for
holiday
excuse me but the application was
was submitted in 2010 was approved and
supported by team bridge district
council and
indus heritage has a preferable scheme
to a holiday lodge's commission which
was granted in 1989
and enacted the 1989 commission is
therefore extend
and recognized by the council as such
unfortunately due to the financial
crisis at the time
the project was never started and
planning
expired planning renewal was applied for
in 2016
and went to appeal which was upheld by
the inspector
but again the project has not been
started for many reasons have not leaked
the pandemic
with its devastating impact on the
tourism and the hospitality sector
hence the owners have again applied for
permission hoping that the project will
be able to start as soon as conditions
are more favorable the scheme is
identical in all respects that permitted
by the council in 2011
and subsequently allowed on appeal in
2017.
i just like to say that we support the
officer's recommendation
for approval thank you very much thank
you
okay um so chris if you could now
um move the public speaker to the
waiting room as is your normal practice
oh yeah he's in there now right thank
you
um okay well as before no award member
to speak on this one um i'll explain
what my view is and what others may wish
to come in um
as i see the situation the existing uh
appeal decision is the most significant
point here
and um given that even though one might
have some sympathy with the views
expressed about the
by one of our officers about the impact
on the
on the heritage assets i would have to
go along with the recommendations before
us
because it's
in line with the previous appeal
decision
anyone else wish to say anything
i'll move the recommendation and if
nobody else wishes to speak uh
i'll move the recommendation um on the
agenda which is
thank you chair um i just give given
that it's been um
a sort of um an issue that's come up in
several
uh planning applications i just wonder
whether there had been a carbon
calculation presented for this
application
um i'm not sure whether councillor hook
is still in the meeting but she's
usually
sort of pretty hot on these issues i'd
i'm not sure whether that's relevant for
this development or
if so whether had been provided um
yeah i think that's just the one point i
wanted to ask really thank you
yeah well councillor hook has declared
an interest in this item because of her
um you know sort of close friendship
with the applicant
um it is a question i did ask of uh of
ross eastman
at my pre-meeting with her um so whether
she'd
wish to comment on the principles of
that i did
say well councillor hook's not going to
be uh speaking but i i asked the
question so
ross did you want to comment on that
please
uh yeah sure the the application isn't a
major application it's a scheme for nine
restricted dwellings so it's the mages
that have to submit a carbon calculator
the requirement for other other schemes
less than
um ten dwellings is that they uh
demonstrate how they've sought to
to minimize their carbon footprint and
whilst we've had limited information
in those explicit terms in relation to
this site
and the fact that we have um solar
panels on the roof and
that uh it would be a uh you know a
modern building built in accordance with
um uh current building regular if not
future building regs um together with
the fact
that we've previously demonstrated
support for domestic tourism as a
potential alternative to international
tourism
uh meant that we were satisfied that the
in in this instance were
uh acceptable and uh compliant compliant
with um
en3 uh taylor is there anything else
specifically that
that we wanted to mention um uh anything
i've missed or does that cover it
no i think that covers it i was just
going to mention yeah the solar panels
and the support for domestic tourism
right thank you both um councilman
bradford
thank you chair i just um wanted to ask
the
trees in the in the picture if those
trees are going to be
left there i know there are some going
to be planted but are those
ones that are there are they going to be
laugh please
yeah so all of the um trees that are
currently on site
will will remain it's just the fruit
trees that can be planted to the south
of the site there new
uh all existing hedgerows and trees will
remain
thank you uh i thought council mcgregor
you did have your hand up that
um doesn't appear to be now no it's been
covered by by
okay thank you um and um
councilman bradford your hand and take
that down now i presume
right um well i had moved the
recommendation and set out
um with the 12 conditions and then that
wasn't seconded because
cancer patch came in i think um they
hadn't been able to get my attention
so council goodman bradbury has put a
hand up so are you seconding
i'm happy to second that chair right
okay thank you
nobody else wishing to speak that was
indicated in which case then can we go
to the vote
so the vote is that permission be
granted
as set out in the agenda so chris can
you take us through that please
thank you chair councillor bradford
abstain um counselor clarence
what counselor colclough oh
councillor cox
sorry for councillor hayes
councillor jeffrey councillor mcgregor
four councillor nuttall
councillor nutley or councillor patch
four counselor goodman bradbury
four and councillor haynes
i believe that's eleven four and one
abstention yep that's correct so um
that is approved the permission has been
granted
right can we move on now then please to
the final application on the list that's
six e
which is apple gas bishop stanton
and we have speakers on this one
so can you please
bring them into the meeting chris yeah
we're just waiting for the supporter to
turn the camera on
sure oh yeah we'll just tell you
something over there
okay thank you right so and they're both
muted thank you so
um speakers i'll ask you to unmute when
it's your turn to speak i'll invite you
to speak once we've had the
presentation from the officer okay so
we're all here
which case uh tell you it's you again
please
thank you
okay so again there are no further
updates since the office report was
published
so this application seeks full planning
permission for the subdivision of the
existing garden
at the property known as applegath and
the construction of a new two-story
dwelling with associated off-street
parking area
so here you can see the site in its
surrounding context
with the road of for the lane running
south of the site
and the cul-de-sac of little field
running to the north
and here's a photograph of the existing
garden at applegath applegath would be
to the left of this photograph
and you can see the adjacent properties
of littlefield in the background there
as well
so the proposed dwelling would sit to
the east of the property of applegath
and would take both its pedestrian and
vehicular access off littlefield
given the levels of the site entry to
the property will be at first floor
level
with all living space to be on this
level to include a balcony area to the
south
three bedrooms are proposed at ground
floor level leading out to a
rear garden area
here's a view of the south elevation
showing the distance between the
proposed dwelling
and the existing property of applegath
to be approximately 18 meters
and proposed balcony can be seen here on
the south elevation as well
a view of the west elevation showing the
difference in site levels
between the road of littlefield here on
the left of the screen
the porch entrance to the new property
coming down to the rear garden area here
underneath the balcony
and then down again to fold a lane
and a view of the north elevation
showing the extent of the underbuild
of the new property with the proposed
dwelling appearing as one story from
littlefield
and the proposed vehicular and
pedestrian access as well
and a view of the east elevation again
showing the difference in levels to the
properties on littlefield here to the
right of the screen
coming down to the new property and the
rear garden area
in terms of character there are a
variety of different styles of property
in the media area
properties to the north of the site on
littlefield are shown on screen now
properties to the south of the site
directly opposite on forder lane
and in between the two roads of for the
lane and littlefield
so this is the existing property of
applegath here shown to the left of the
screen
the application site just to the right
of this to the left of apple gas is the
existing property of treetops
again with a balcony there on the
southern elevation
and to the left of this is a small uh
is called merely close with a group of
properties coming off this as well
and this is the street scene as proposed
so you can see the new dwelling here on
the right of the screen
adjacent to the existing property of
applegath and again further to the west
the existing property of treetops
with regard to overlooking from the site
this photograph is taken from the
proposed garden area of the new property
looking south towards the properties on
for the lane
the boundary vegetation typically
reaches the height of this post shown on
screen here
that has been recently removed by the
applicant following instruction from
devon county highways
the distance between where i am stood in
this picture taking the photograph
and the house's opposite is roughly 20.5
meters
here's a view directly south east from
the proposed rear garden area
a view directly east towards the
adjacent attached garages
and a view north towards properties on
littlefield
here's a photograph showing a view from
the corner of the southern elevation of
the new
property towards the existing property
of applegath
and this distance is roughly 18 meters
from elevation to elevation
you can see the edge of the proposed
parking area here on screen
where the white fence is at the top of
the photograph here
so the proposed access is to be taken
off littlefield with space for two
parked cars
whilst there is currently some informal
on-street car parking occurring on
littlefield
it is considered that the access itself
is suitable
and can be utilized safely by two cars
the county highways engineer has also
visited the site itself
and has no highways objection and has
agreed that the turning circle is
similar
to those of the adjacent garages and
properties further up littlefield
given that littlefield is a cul-de-sac
traffic is relatively light
and visibility can be achieved to
vehicles traveling at these lower speeds
the parking arrangements for applegath
remain the same as existing
it's considered that the site can
accommodate the additional dwelling
without having
any adverse impact on the character of
the local area and residential amenity
and therefore i am recommending approval
of this application subject to
conditions
thank you thank you
okay um so um if i
ask the objector shown there first
please to
um unmute and then it's
um three minutes each um
and obviously we have an indication when
times up
and time starts when you start speaking
okay thank you
thank you the local planning office aims
are to protect and enhance the interests
of communities
we believe that this application fails
against these criteria
the strength of feeling regarding this
is clearly evidenced by the 36
objectives to the prose development
including parish council and the
sustainable bishop statement group
as a community we collectively agree
that this application constitutes the
overdevelopment
of what is in effect a village garden
there is a covenant on applegath site
which prohibits the construction of
further properties within its grounds
we would like to ensure that this has
been taken into consideration
the teambridge local plan states that
the development should perform well
against i quote
the impact on the residential amenity of
existing buildings
particularly with regard to privacy
outlook light and security
the applicant's plan reinforced desire
to make the most of the views from the
proposed
new property with apparent disregard for
the existing properties of the rear and
foreground
who will lose their current outlook and
privacy and will experience a reduction
in their natural light
the new building proposes its entrance
from littlefield which is a narrow
and often congested road vehicles
wanting access from a proposed driveway
onto littlefield
will have limited visibility resulting
in additional dangers to other road
users including pedestrians
the highways department suggested
visibility displays from the proposed
access could be achieved
albeit with some removal of hedges
ultimately
this could mean an even greater section
of the existing hedgerows is removed
the proposed vehicle accessed the new
house would only reinforce problems or
an experienced by residents
refuse emergency and commercial vehicles
there has been a history of traffic and
parking problems at the junction of
littlefield and folderlane
resulting in double yellow lines being
added recently
as a neighborhood since the development
of applegath we have seen a destruction
of an established garden
mature trees felled removal of a
thriving pond
and the subsequent impact on the
environment and biodiversity
it is very clear in the teenage plan
that these are the things we should be
striving to preserve the scale and
design of the new build
result in an elevated house extending
above the hedge lines
dominating the small plot and adversely
affecting the appearance of the road
the plan involving deep excavation of
the site very close to the boundaries of
littlefield and flor de lane
is a serious concern knowing there are
subterranean watercourses in this part
of the village
there is a real possibility that the
excavation work could result in
subsidence or structural damage
i have lived in the village for over 40
years witnessed and supported some
character
developments so this is by no means a
case of
not in my backyard this development goes
against all we're trying to develop
locally in trying to create a greener
more sustainable community
should this proposal be approved it will
inevitably set a precedent for building
on other
inappropriate sites around the village
the sole beneficiary of this
will be the development developer at the
expense of the neighborhood
community and village in general on
behalf of the local time
thank you
thank you okay if i could now
ask the supporter again three minutes
if the objective could you please mute
your microphone now
thank you okay supporter thank you
good afternoon i represent white cove
architecture can you
turn up your volume on your device
slightly yeah sure then we'll restart
the
no worries
okay to go yeah go on good afternoon i
represent white cove architecture and
speak on behalf of the client
who send their apologies for not
presenting today given the arrival of
their first baby is now nine days
overdue
i hope to reinforce the points raised by
the planning officer and demonstrate
that the proposal fully considers the
height
scale and character of the surrounding
area to ensure that bishop state and
special
character and appearance is preserved
and enhanced
as required by policy s2 of the local
plan the materials proposed respond to
the local material palette
as the properties to the west north and
south differ widely in style and
character
the proposal replicates the immediate
neighbors at applegath and treetops
with timber cladding and off-white
vendor the design approach and
materiality were considered appropriate
at pre-application
the form of the proposal was designed to
reduce overall massing and visual impact
the significant level changes presented
by the site and show the dwelling will
appear subservient when viewed from
littlefield and florida lane
with privacy formed by the natural
boundary of the retained existing hedges
the asymmetrical design reduces the
overall height allowing a lower pitch
and ridge level than that of a more
traditional hipped roof
given the separation distance of 20.5
meters the proposal will not give rise
to any issue of privacy or overlooking
to any property on florida lane
and is in excess of the cambridge design
guide to back-to-back arrangements
no windows are proposed to the north and
there is limited glazing to the side
elevations
the south elevation is almost identical
to the neighboring treetops property
where the approved two-story extension
also included parking and access from
littlefield
access is proposed to be from the
property's address at littlefield in
order to enter at the same level as the
living accommodation and negate the need
for shared parking with the neighbours
at applegath
in respect to the opposing party's
concerns the proposal now accommodates
two off-street parking spaces
as to not affect the existing condition
on littlefield
a highways officer from devon county
council confirmed the proposed
arrangement
is acceptable we recognize there has
been a number of objections to the
proposal but would politely point out
that some neighbors have submitted more
than one
and we have a copy of a letter
circulated encouraging of us to propose
oppose following pre-application we have
worked with cambridge council to make
several changes to reduce any potential
impacts of the development
including reducing the height by 0.5
metres in the southern boundary by 1.4
increasing the lower garden by 10 square
meters additional off-street parking
provision
and reducing the number and size of
windows to the west elevation
the land is surplus to the requirements
of applegath and the development will
provide additional housing within an
area of holy residential and
well-serviced properties
i politely ask that you vote to approve
this application in accordance with your
office's recommendation
thank you for your time thank you
okay chris if you could um
move the speakers back to the
waiting room thank you um there's one
question i have or i'd like the sort of
reply from
taya or or rosnatz an item raised by the
uh objector about covenants my
understanding is that covenants
aren't a consideration that we take into
account here for planning
that's a separate issue for the
beneficiaries of any
covenants to pursue themselves because i
just have
confirmation that is the case please
um yeah yeah that's correct so uh it's
important to note that any planning
permission wouldn't override any
restrictions that are currently on the
covenant to the property
and that would be for the applicant to
address themselves
yeah or indeed for the beneficiaries of
the covenants to
um pursue it okay um
right board member that's council
mcgregor
it seems like i'm getting quite a lot of
air time today chair and i do apologize
if i'm
hugging the hugging the limelight um one
of the reasons why i i called this in
was there was quite a significant um
feeling expressed across the the
community
in particular i think the the the view
is that
in a village like bishop stanton and i'm
sure it's reflected across many villages
and towns
in the district is the idea of constant
infill infill infill
we end up with the loss of the
feel and look of a village or a town
um and this this is quite a significant
um
infill slot because it's an infill
that's viewed
not just from the the one street but
from from two streets and and a close
nearby as well and it does have a
significant impact in in that
respect in terms of the the um
the highways matter i think it's quite
important to
um look at the plan um and and ask
ourselves really with the turn in
that that's there um we're going to have
two cars coming out of that property
reversing into
littlefield into an area where cars are
parked
on the pavement and forcing
pedestrians to walk down littlefield in
the middle of the road
and without significant loss of the
hedgerow uh and i mean
considerable more than syndicated in the
the plan
um the the visibility for cars coming
out of
the proposed property would be very
limited indeed
so what we're potentially looking at
here is a reduction in hedgerow
that is significant and so when i hear
claims of oh it'll improve biodiversity
on the site
i think that that actually would be
extremely questionable because
effectively we're building um you know
we're seeing built on
a significant piece of a garden we're
seeing a removal of a
well-established hedgerow and verge um
and that actually indicates that it's
not going to be a gain in biodiversity
all
it's going to be a lot of biodiversity
so i think there are there are several
elements to the
the the um proposal so far that really
don't chime with with what's really
being being proposed
um it's also in the undeveloped coast
area
and again you know bearing in mind the
infill element to it
it does have a significant impact in the
look and feel of the village
um we are seeing you know and we got
admitted from the planning officer that
there is overlooking from
uh the proposed development into the
house's opposite side of the road on
four de lane
um the view is limited by the fact that
the house is
significantly uh you know sorry the
houses
opposite are of a significant size and
their bedrooms are going to be at the
height of the balcony
um there isn't a huge amount of space
between
the the building and the the property
line
edging forward the road so effectively
it's only a very
short distance in reality between the
two properties on either side of
florida for the uh ford delane itself
is at that particular point is extremely
busy
always um one side of the road is parked
it you can't get two cars going um
you know down that road at the same time
in opposite directions because there
isn't the width there
and as we can see from the photographs
presented by the planning officer
there is a significant um reduction in
width there
for any vehicles because of the parking
on the pavement
um and then obviously the the subsequent
uh issues that we have then with
pedestrians
and cyclists being at risk as well so um
that covers my points um my view is that
i would recommend
to go against officers uh recommendation
on this instance on the basis
that it is infill and it does change the
character and feel of that particular
part of the village
okay thank you did anyone else wish to
speak
counselor hook
thank you chad um i just feel um
always obviously you have to consider
applications within the planning
legislation that we have
and so when i look at this um
i'm i'm struggling to be honest to find
um
good planning reasons to re to refuse it
um so it is on a relatively large sized
plot um with and the building itself
takes up a similar percentage of that
plot
as do others within the immediate
vicinity
it has two parking spaces um
the planning officer hasn't judged there
to be overlooking issues
i don't believe there are design issues
um looking at the variety of designs
that are
around um i don't think
we can talk about precedent i mean
obviously we
often have these applications that come
to us we treat them all
as individual applications on their
merits and that's exactly what we're
doing here
so i don't see why this happening acts
as a precedent for anything else to
happen in the village
um and i don't believe um it's
fundamentally
unsustainable to build in a location
such as this in fact one could argue
exactly the opposite that it is
sustainable
to build within um the village
envelope as it currently is is is a
sustainable thing to do
um so personally i'm struggling to find
good reasons
to refuse this the only one thing i
would add on
is that um i would like to see
the parking or at least one of those
parking spaces made ev
ready not necessarily with the
current charging facility but to be ev
ready
for somebody that um was to live in that
house and wanted to
um install the latest charging facility
so that's the only thing and that does
conform to policy s9 of our um
local plan to ask for that facility so i
would ask
for that to be added in but other than
that i i'm struggling to see good
planning reasons and that's what we're
here to do
judge things by the planning legislation
that we have at the moment
thank you thank you well i entirely
agree with with all that you said
um i'm not entirely sure about the
policy situation
uh for the charging at this point so
perhaps we could have
clarification on that from the officer
if that's anything that we can add as a
condition
taya
yeah it's something that um i don't
think the applicant would necessarily be
opposed to
they seem willing to include
enhancements such as that
okay thank you so um
yeah looking at it i mean it's a
domestic
garden and hedge so uh i see
the the um hedge that's removed to to
give the height
the access for parking as being entirely
um acceptable um the highways officer
has given their view
um the fact that vehicles park on the
road isn't uh the applicants
doing and and they are providing the
required spaces
on this site so i can see no issues
there
the overlooking distance is the
properties be to the north
are at a higher level and i don't see an
issue particularly giving a lack of
windows to the north
and it's lower setting there's only
single story that way
and to the south the balcony there is a
balcony on the property the other side
of applegath
and distances are not dissimilar if
anything perhaps slightly further
and i can't see um there are issues
because you're overlooking into the
front garden beyond the busy
as we're told public highway so i can
i'm struggling to find any reasons
so counselor hope did you wish to move
with that additional condition about the
ev
charging point for the the conditions
that are set out in the agenda
approval um well i could do um i
i thought that had there been another
recommendation i can't
recall right no as on it says on the
agenda but you were you were
suggesting the um charging point for the
vehicle
as an additional one yeah and i'd be
happy to second that
um does anyone else wish to speak
i've got nobody else raising their
electronic hand now council called after
you've unmuted did you wish to speak
i was going to second the proposal from
google but it's been done
okay thank you right um
councilman bradford
i'm i'm just a bit perturbed about this
hedgerow that's been taken away
well it's a domestic it's not it's not
as though it was a hedgerow you know
sort of
agricultural field in the countryside
we're talking about a domestic
hedgerow which um you know sort of is
something that
in an urban area um isn't a thing that
um is of any consequence shall we say in
terms of what
we would normally not permit
okay i've got council mcgregor wishing
to come back again
um thanks chair uh it's just
just to say you know i do accept your
point it is in um
an urban setting but that particular
garden
and that particular hedge are untouched
um and undisturbed in real terms look
like
and if you look at the pictures of the
garden it's quite
um it's quite unkempt you know so we are
you know i think we do need to recognize
that there is going to be a loss of
biodiversity not again
um from developing this site um
that biodiversity whether we we call it
a rural or an urban
uh hedgerow is is significant and and i
think we do need to to be cognizant of
that as well
okay anybody else we should speak
no in which case then the motion before
us is that
um permission be granted with the
conditions set out plus the
electronic electric vehicle charging
point
um so can i ask chris to take the vote
on that please
thank you chair um how's the bradford
against councillor clarence
port councillor colclough oh
councillor cox epstein
councillor hayes
councillor hook
councillor jeffrey councillor mcgregor
against councillor nuttall
abstain counselor nutley
engaged counselor patch
councillor governor bradbury four
and councillor haynes
um i had that as eight three two chair
that's correct eight four three against
and two abstentions so that's carrier
permission
is granted thank you so then we move on
to the
final item on the agenda which is the
appeal decisions to be noted
anything that uh roles you wish to say
on that at all
no i don't think so thank you chad these
are two fairly straightforward decisions
okay thank you in which case then that
brings us to the end of
today's committee meeting so thank you
all for
your participation in that and um i look
forward to seeing you soon
um and hopefully one day back in the
in the council chamber okay so feel free
to log off and
cheerio thanks chair bye bye
thank you thanks very much